when you're in a room and you hear about
those schools everything gets silent
everything gets awkward everything gets
melancholy I can't have that when people
hear Stoneman Douglas I don't want them
to think about people crying I want them
to think about people taking action no
matter what that action might be
I can't wait for today's Sunday special
with Cameron Caskey from middle ground
we'll get to talk with Cameron in just
one second but first let's talk about
your privacy online whether you're in a
cafe or a hotel we often rely on public
Wi-Fi to use the internet on the go but
something as simple as paying your bills
online from a Starbucks can leave your
data exposed a hacker can easily
intercept that information stealing
passwords credit card numbers personal
details it's not just hackers either
government agencies like the NSA they
monitor the Internet you don't know what
they're doing with that information so
what can you use to defend yourself well
the software I use to protect my online
activity from spies and data thieves
it's called expressvpn expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that runs seamlessly in
the background of my computer phone and
tablet expressvpn secures and anonymizes
my internet browsing by encrypting that
data hiding my public IP address using
expressvpn I can safely surf on public
Wi-Fi without being snooped down or
having my personal data stolen for the
best protection you should use Express
VPN every time you go online Express VPN
cost less than seven bucks a month it
comes with a 30-day money-back guarantee
so you really have nothing to lose to
take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months for free go to expressvpn comm
slash Ben that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
been for three months free with a
one-year package again Express VPN and
secure your internet now expressvpn comm
slash Ben to learn more Cameron thank
you so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it thank you for having me
so from folks who don't know Cameron was
one of the students at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in parkland Florida
when the when the awful shooting took
place and he was subsequently a member
of March for lives now he is one of the
leaders of a group called middle ground
are you a founder of middle ground yes I
am okay so tell us a little bit about
middle ground then we'll kind of
backtrack and talk about how we got here
so one of the lessons I've learned since
starting March for our lives and this
was a truly difficult one to grasp was
that surprisingly enough I don't know
everything now as a 17 year old boy who
was dead set on the fact that I knew
everything that was that threw me for a
loop and halfway through my tour with
March for our lives the summer
where we were advocating for more
accessible voting and encouraging people
to register I realized I was in I was in
Texas and I spoke to some people maybe
the people who disagree with me don't
want the country to be a bad place maybe
they just have different views and I was
born in a bubble where my heavily
liberal mindset that I still maintain
convinced me that anybody who didn't
agree with me was had mal-intent and and
they didn't I thought the people who
didn't agree with me on gun laws didn't
care when kids died that's not the case
I learned a lot of things so I thought
how can I prevent people from making the
mistakes that I made we've got a really
engaged young generation there's no lack
of passion but there's a lack of
information and there's a lack of
civility very frequently and very often
there is there is incivility and the
guise of passion and that's fine but I I
want to move into the future with a more
humanized look at politics I think that
everybody in the country well I would
call 96% of the country wants the
country to be a better place how do we
fix this that I mean we're in a more
polarized place than ever what can we do
to make this better so I thought to
create a program called middle ground
and at middle ground we would really
explore everybody's perspectives my
personally my opinion hasn't changed but
my opinions on opinions have changed I
disagree with me I want to learn from
them because I'm a child
I can't rent a car I can't I can't buy a
house I'm not the expert on everything
and very frequently I'm treated like the
expert on things and you know I believe
that my insight is valuable I think that
a fact whether spoken by a three year
old or a 70 year old is still a fact and
insight is subjective but I want to
create a more educated youth well that's
really obviously mature and I have a lot
of sympathy for you because you were
sort of thrust into the public eye in a
fashion you obviously never expected or
wanted you know I've been in the public
eye at your age and it's definitely
difficult thing in the lesson that you
learned you learned faster than I
learned it for sure
and so that's that's definitely a path
you've had to take so let's let's go
back to the beginning what exactly so
let's start with you as a person sure
where we where were you born what's your
family like so I was born in Hollywood
but Hollywood Florida I
grew up in South Florida I my parents
got divorced when I was 10 I was luckily
lucky enough to get two amazing
stepparents not everybody gets those I
was happily raised by you know for
people who really had a great dialog
with each other very respectful and very
understanding of me I was known as the
easiest kid to raise I have an older
brother who is actually pretty easy to
raise and a younger brother who has
autism surprisingly enough my younger
brother who does have special needs
requires the least attention of the
three of us I have a stepsister who's
lovely as well I mean I'm definitely the
worst person in my family and I think
I'm a good person so that's saying
something and you know I grew up with a
very liberal mindset I was knocking
doors for Obama when I was seven years
old I there was lack of information for
me I thought that John McCain was
running with Tina Fey because I had seen
on the news that Tina Fey was Palin and
I wasn't able to put two and two
together but I I always cared because I
always thought that I always wanted more
from the country I was a Bobby Kennedy
fanatic for a while because I like
people who look at the future and that's
really what gave me the progressive
mindset is I'm not opposed to
conservative views but I think that a
lot of conservatism will have people
thinking more of using the pass passed
as a model as opposed to a springboard I
think there's always somewhere we can go
I think everything can be better and
that was always my mindset so I was
always very vocal very loud very
obnoxious very flippantly rude and I
found theater which was really a way for
me to take my voice in and hone it and
find something I cared about so I
started doing plays and musicals I
sounded like crap but I sang a lot and
and it helped me a lot it helped me
become expressive it helped me empathize
with people I mean did you ever do plays
in high school or anything I didn't know
no lose it all boys school so wasn't
that much weekend Josh you well well
acting it helps you understand other
people a lot because you have to put
yourself in other people's shoes
sometimes it's easy and people can just
read a script and and become someone
else but I it took a lot more for me I
very often played a bad guy which what
didn't really help me I played are you
familiar with Little Shop of Horrors I
was the dentist and there's not a lot of
humanity you can search for it's hard to
put yourself in the shoes of somebody
who is a psychopath but you know I got
obviously I would
for me but but I you know I developed a
deep empathy for my fellow human being
that I that drove me very to a very
passionate and emotional stance then my
school gets shot up and I say okay I've
heard of Sandy Hook I've heard of
Columbine I've heard all these things
and when you're in a room and you hear
about those schools everything gets
silent everything gets awkward
everything gets melancholy I can't have
that when I when people hear Stoneman
Douglas I don't want them to think about
people crying I want them to think about
people taking action no matter what that
action might be so take me through that
day what what exactly was that day like
for you so before the shooting I was in
my drama class we were halfway through a
song that I was doing again I sounded
like hot garbage but I remembered the
special-needs kids at my school are let
out a half hour before everybody else
because they're picked up at the bus
loop and they have to be picked up
before the bus has come so on days where
I at school and my mother was at work I
picked up my brother and I brought up to
drama he loved and he got attention from
the girls he felt like you know he felt
like a cool guy which he is and it was
about 220 and I was supposed to pick him
up at 210 so I said oh crap I gotta go I
rush out of the drama room run over to
pick up my brother because I have to be
back for my song and suddenly there's a
fire alarm and I say oh the busses are
about to come and I'm with the
special-needs students and we have to go
in the bus loop to avoid the fire you
know there are a lot of very
high-functioning students in the ESC
program at soman Douglas there are a lot
of lower functioning students but it's
it's a hassle to get in the parking lot
and I was just like okay this is
annoying especially being outside of the
class you're supposed to be in during a
fire drill cuz then you have to tell the
teacher they have to walkie the staff to
make sure everybody's accounted for and
while we're out there waiting this kid
near me says shooter I look at him and I
say what did that's not cool that's not
cool at all I said something very
inappropriate you know if this reaches
the younger audience someone avoid it
but suddenly everybody starts running
back into the school and there are
teachers beckoning us inside and my
initial thought is okay we're with the
ESC class and several other classes but
we're with the ESC class in the middle
of the of the bus loop and there was a
it must have been a fake fire drill and
the buses were about to come so they're
like everybody get inside so you don't
get hit by the buses then we're sent
into a classroom the lights turn off and
I say something's going on here
took me a couple minutes to realize that
there was there was gunfire I heard
conflicting rumors it was massive it was
it was hysteria in the room but it was
the type of hysteria where you are
hysterical but still have to be quiet
because you don't know what the gunman
is he could have been you know right
right next door to us I had no idea I
didn't hear any gunfire I thought I did
but when you know there's a shooter and
you hear something you think it's
gunfire it's natural
and everybody was telling me conflicting
stories and this was just the people
next to us they were whispering they
said fifty people were killed two people
were killed this teacher was killed that
wasn't this person was the shooter this
person with the shooter and I spent the
whole time thinking I really really
really hope my brother doesn't
understand what's going on and and
that's a moral qualms do I tell him
what's going on because he deserves the
truth or do I allow him the ignorance of
no the bliss of ignorance for the time
being but there were also a lot of other
special needs students there and some of
them were nonverbal but nonverbal
doesn't mean you can't make noise and
some of them were yelling some of them
were making loud shrieks and hollers and
fortunately the special needs specialist
had someone Douglass were able to keep
everybody together and it was it was a
problem that was solved quickly but
we're eight we were able to be released
the SWAT team came in with first thing
we saw was rifle in the glass crack so
we thought we were toast
but the SWAT team came in we run outside
I get picked up by my parents at a hotel
a couple hours later and and then came a
week of chaos but also peace did all of
the laws of physics kind of didn't exist
in Parkland It was as if the world had
stopped there was this eerie calm but
also this fiery madness it was it was a
time where I said in this in this lack
of while nobody around us knows what's
going on I have to step up and say
here's what I think I couldn't have the
carrot the cameras game and I couldn't
have them come and film people crying I
had to have them come and I had to have
people stand in front of them and say we
cannot have this anymore we demand a
change
we are not parkland is not the city of
people who are going to encourage you to
join our melancholy parkland is the city
of people who are going to encourage you
to take action if you could add your
druthers about how the media treats
these sorts of situations obviously you
don't I mean we
the media does what the media do which
is they cover the news when it happens
but if you could have had your druthers
emotionally just politically in every
way what would you what would you have
the media how did you have the media
covered these sorts of situations well
it's a double-edged sword because on the
one hand I was on national news while
there were bodies that were still warm
and people hadn't been buried yet and
that made that at the time I didn't
really think about it but in retrospect
it makes me question was that
appropriate on the one hand the cameras
are gonna leave and I want to make sure
the message that I believe is right gets
across while the cameras are still there
on the other hand people are dead and
and I know I don't regret anything I did
because I know that what I was doing I
did because I believed it was right and
that's the best I can do but in regards
to how the media covers it I think that
the names of shooters should never be
released daily wire covers that very
well I know that there are multiple
pundits as well that do not name the
shooters I think that there's a that
making the shooter celebrities is
flippantly inappropriate I think that I
think that I was very often treated like
an expert when I'm not I'm not the
expert on anything so in the days
immediately following obviously there
are a lot of cameras there people are
looking to you for comment when did you
and and the other members of March fire
lives really start to consolidate into a
group sure so February 15th we were all
a bit separated and it was February 16th
two days after the shooting that I was
able to kind of see who was ready to
speak out and get them together we all
came to my house I thought of doing the
March in DC and my Ghostbusters pajamas
in my bathroom and and I said okay every
the whole nation in in one way or
another is galvanized right now what can
we do how can we materialize this and I
said let's get everyone to DC and let's
demand a change so quickly the team
started to grow more and more people
became part all my friends from Douglas
they knew we're well-spoken and eloquent
joined some people just showed up at my
house and some of them ended up becoming
very passionate and well-spoken
advocates for what we were advocating
for but it was but by what I would call
February 19th
our team was together so the tactics
that March for our lives used came under
a lot of Chris's criticism including
from people like me because obviously at
the very beginning particularly there
was a lot of focus on some of the stuff
you talked about
earlier there's an implication that was
put out by particular members of the
team you know in in public settings that
if there was a disagreement about
politics that this is a reflection of
lack of care about what had happened um
what do you think could have been done
to mitigate against that to be honest
with you a lot of that was me a lot of
that was me telling my friends you know
these people don't agree with us that
they don't care you know they they care
more about their guns than they care
about kids getting killed anything all
criticized about March for lives really
comes from me I started it I was my I
was whispering and my friends hears the
whole time I know I know the people in
March for our lives I know them pretty
much like the back of my hand I know
that these are people who really just
want the world to be a better place and
a lot of our errors and messaging
particularly if you don't like us you
don't care came from me and I believed
it and I believed it until relatively
recently
I'm embarrassed certainly but I'm also
I'm not losing sleep over it because I
believed it what do you think changed
that for you I mean you talked about
being in Texas but obviously like that
for those of us were watching from afar
the first time that I saw you on TV I
think was probably during the CNN Town
Hall event which was obviously got huge
ratings was was a big television event I
criticized Jake Tapper for it because I
suggested that the media really should
have if they want to have a discussion
the issues they should do a discussion
of the issues as opposed to sort of an
emotionally driven event you know what
changed from from there to where you are
now which is if somebody who wants to
have discussions based on the issues I I
think I I reached out for a bit I can
tell you the exact catalyst there wasn't
really a moment where I clicked on me
that I need to start opening these
conversations but I realized look the
the left's never gonna get rid of the
right the rights never gonna get rid of
the left they certainly evolved the
parties change over time but there's as
long as we have a binary system it's a
binary system and and half the country
doesn't want the world to be a bad place
I thought that I thought that half the
country the Republicans we're evil I
think that there are some great people
on the right and left are both lovely
and people on the right and left are
both awful I don't want to say there's
very fine people on both sides because
that has been used in ways I can never
accept but I I learned that that there's
a such a that we're all people
I mean I said this yesterday a lot of
people were politicizing 9/11 and and I
said look we're Americans today and I
learned that overall we're Americans and
we have a you know there's a Creed
there's a national understanding that we
need to be a better place and right now
looking back it didn't it didn't used to
be like this I think this has been a
long time coming I think that right now
our socio-political fabric is not only
bad because of Trump I think Trump
doesn't do anything good for it
I think Trump is too focused on owning
the libs and and not uniting the country
but this is this we've earned this
we America as a whole is responsible for
this division then we need to come
together okay so I'm going to ask a
bunch more questions about sort of your
political perspective how it's changed
and where you are now in just one second
but first let's talk about life
insurance so September is national life
insurance awareness month if you listen
to this show a lot you've heard me talk
about how important life insurance is
you got a family you want to make sure
they're taken care of in case god forbid
something happens to you but here's the
thing 40% of Americans still don't have
life insurance so if anything were to
happen to their families to you their
families could be left in a really
difficult financial situation these days
there's not really an excuse for not
having it because life insurance rates
are 220 or low it's easier than ever to
buy it especially if you use policy
genius policy genius is the easy way to
get life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find the best policy for
you and when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy they
also do disability insurance renter's
insurance health insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so if you're
looking for a good reason to buy life
insurance there are three it's national
life insurance awareness month rates are
to twenty year low and policy genius
makes it easy to get the right policy
for you it is really important go get
life insurance now go to policy genius
com get quotes apply in minutes you can
do the whole thing on your phone right
now
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance ok so we
obviously are sweat came to some of the
emotional response to what had happened
now that you've kind of moved toward
trying to pursue a conversation it was
something I noticed earlier with you by
the way on Twitter I remember you and I
had an exchange on Twitter and it was
actually relatively cordial you said
something I responded and it was about
Chicago I think that's right exactly
goggle gun violence being tied to
Indiana exactly and so we just kind of
went back and forth on that and then you
made some comments and I liked them and
I
this is good what you're doing here and
and I thought this is somebody who's
actually considering you know how to how
to go about making the country a better
place why do you think that you had to
break from March for our lives why not
stick around and try and change the
thing from the inside for example well I
at the end of the day March for our
lives is advocating for things that I'm
currently not advocating for now on a
policy stance I agree with March for
lives almost entirely and they are
currently involved with advocating for
policy change they're involved with
raising awareness about gun violence in
parts of the country that are very often
forgotten and I have tremendous amount
of respect for that and I'm proud of my
friends truly I believe that my friends
are great people who really want the
country to be a better place and I'm
proud to cheer them on to the future
proud to help but right now I'm focused
more on social things I'm focused more
on the fact that we all have that family
member that's why we can't talk about
Trump and Thanksgiving and and I think
that we need to destabilize these
conversations March for our lives is a
is advocating for policy I'm advocating
for for conversation so I couldn't be
connected to March for our lives when I
was so focused on other things it was
bad for March our lives it was bad for
me I'm proud of my friends I always will
be and I'm doing something else so what
are the conversations that you're trying
to pursue obviously you're here so this
is part of the conversation we'll talk
policy in a little bit but what are the
other kind of conversations you're
trying to pursue and how are you going
about doing that I think that the
strangely enough the conversation that
needs to be pursued is the conversation
about conversations is the fact that you
know if I'm speaking to somebody who
does not share my views on abortion that
does not mean that they are they want to
kill babies or they want to oppress
women I think that if I'm talking to
somebody about the israel-palestine
issue and they one side of the issue
doesn't net doesn't hate Jews and one
side of the issue doesn't hate
Palestinians I think that we need to
stop it you said this to me before we
need to stop the left and the right need
to stop attacking each other's worst
arguments I think that's a big problem
so I'm here to say well where can not
even where can we agree but how can we
approach this respectfully so you cease
here you're you were progressive on
politics before you're progressive on
politics now so what is your stance on
gun control I think that no citizen of
this country needs to have
semi-automatic rifle I also think that
when I'm an adult I will get a concealed
carry permit and if you try to hurt my
family I'm gonna hurt you okay so what
do you think is the difference between I
don't mean to grill you and politics I'm
sure but but what do you think is the
difference between a handgun and a
semi-automatic rifle in this context I
think that if you look at the situations
we've had in this country where people
have used semi-automatic rifles for mass
shootings we see that a lot of it that
having a semi-automatic rifle will make
people feel empowered and I know that
you know as you would say facts don't
care about your feelings and the facts
will suggest other things but I think
that if somebody is attacking me while a
semi-automatic rifle has a longer range
I think that the that the risk of being
attacked by somebody further range as
opposed to having a semi-automatic
handgun is not as great as the reward of
not allowing people to buy these rifles
I think that from a logical standpoint
there's evidence that shows that people
with these kinds of weapons feel more
powerful if you look at the
psychological analyses of many mass
shooters that it's it's a lot there's a
lot of entitlement there's a lot of an
attempt to be known an attempt to feel
large and powerful and I feel like a
large and powerful gun can frequently
can frequently make people feel that I
also think that the shooting in Las
Vegas could not have been done with
anything but an ar-15 I know the shooter
used a bump stock but if that person
only had semi-automatic handguns and was
firing from that distance then it
wouldn't it wouldn't be as effective now
I understand that that is very often
treated as an anomaly it's very often
treated as an outlier when we discuss
the issues with these shootings but I
think that as long as another one of
these can happen which right now it can
we need to address the issue as it is
now how much of the problem do you think
is the instrument and how much is it the
people considering their you know
hundred two hundred million rifles in
circulation in the United States
probably 100 million handguns in
circulation in the United States is
basically a gun per person in the United
States then barring a full-scale
confiscation of rifles how would you
propose to achieve this I think that the
way I look at it is a lot of attacks
whether it be suicide or shooting and
this is why I very often advocate for
red flag laws even though some people
argue they're unconstitutional I think a
lot of these things are reactionary I
think that a lot of mass shooters will
be able to find a weapon on the black
market or illegally and a lot of them if
they are for if they are if it takes
more time and if they have to go through
a harder process will not be as quick to
do it I watched the video I don't know
why I did but I watched the videos that
my shooter put out and in he said you
will know who I am and that reflects to
me somebody who wants to feel powerful
who has and if you I watched really
everything hours of videos on him which
did I don't know why I did it I like to
think of it as people can't look away
from a car accident and I saw a
reflection of a desire to to be powerful
I've said this several times but I think
that it's something we need to address I
think that between facts and feelings
there's logic and we have to apply it we
have to look at the facts and also apply
our insight well why not start with sort
of the most localized solution so a lot
of these solutions that you're talking
about in terms of gun control our
blanket solutions that affect literally
hundreds of millions of people whereas
for example in in the parkland case it's
pretty obvious that the Broward County
Sheriff's Office was engaged in massive
malfeasance at the very least at the
very least yes and the school board
wasn't very good either right to say the
very least I believe that there are many
changes that can be made on a local
level and I I then began to advocate for
them I think that school safety is
important to focus on and I also think
some aspects of school safety are
dangerous for example I think metal
detectors are are not safe I think that
you've been to an airport there are long
lives of around metal detectors and
getting everybody in one place makes
them just as susceptible to shootings
that's my similarly my issue with single
entry points I know for a fact that
still that the Broward school board had
hundreds of millions of dollars that
were allotted for school safety that are
completely missing and my friend Kenneth
Preston actually covers this a lot of
his investigative journalism he's
fantastic and and there was foul play I
am consistently openly critical of
superintendent Runcie
I will really I will sleep so much more
comfortably at night the second he's
gone
sheriff Israel has I was initially on
his side not because I knew him that was
really why I had met him a couple times
seemed like a nice guy but as time went
on I realized this is horrible know what
Broward sheriff and Broward school board
should have done was say we messed up we
messed up our owning up to it here's how
we messed up here's what we're gonna do
better I would give them a bit of credit
for that
because I think that owning up to your
mistakes is very important that being
said I think that I think that instead
of doing that well I know for a fact
instead of doing that they then went out
and we're touting how great of a school
year was donna corn who ran against mr.
penny the father of one of the victims
at our school said it was an amazing
school year you don't say that when a
school get shot up you don't the end and
it wasn't amazing school year I know for
a fact Stoneman Douglas ran out of
printer paper for a while and we had to
use legal now is that is that a crime
against humanity no but the Broward
School Board has a slew of issues that
they simply refused to own up to I've
made a lot of mistakes in my life
and I hadn't been a pretty short one I
think I've made a bit too many for how
long I've been around we all hood and
it's but I'll own up to them I've said
some dumb stuff I'll tell you that it
was dumb but right now the school board
and the sheriff like you have said they
are not holding themselves accountable
they are not auditing themselves there
there are so many things that they could
do to bring some sort of justice here I
wouldn't even say justice to do
something and they're not so you have to
create a proportional relationship
between what you believe in if you
believe in more gun rights then that's
your own company and we could talk about
that if you believe in gun control
remember that at the end of the day I'm
a gun control advocate but I know guns
don't kill people people kill people the
thing is people very frequently kill
each other with guns no question but
let's let's talk a little bit about the
you talk about the tenor of the
conversation and the contents of the
conversation it seems to me one of the
areas where there could be crossover is
that the the tenor of the conversation
is generated by the content meaning that
when we immediately in the aftermath of
a shooting like this jump to our set
beginning points and that this happens
on Twitter very quickly right there ever
as soon as there's mass shooting one
half of the people on Twitter jump to
let's take all the guns let's ban rifles
let's let's take heavy gun control
action and the other side jump to it was
a it was a safety zone it was a no it
was a gun-free zone let's let we can't
do anything there are certain areas
where to their agreement and what's
weird is that it seems like it's almost
impossible to even have conversations
about those areas of agreement because
both sides are making hay off of the
areas where we disagree so for example
we agree on the actions that the school
board should have taken we I'm sure we
do agree on how the media
should be treating the names of shooters
because it's absurd to glorify shooters
and repeat their names publicly that's
why we don't do it it's a Lee Weyer um
these are area but instead there was a
jump immediately by the media which I
think frankly used you guys of props to
push an agenda that they agree with I
think that CNN agrees with the agenda
that March for lives was pushing and so
they started to push that in a way that
they wouldn't dive after for example the
mass shooting at a church in Texas where
a bunch of the people who were there
were members of the NRA the guy who shot
the the shooter was a member of the NRA
do you feel that the media's bias on
these issues contributes to lack of
understanding I feel like the media's
bias on every issues contributes to lack
of understanding I don't think I think
they're very few publications out there
that that are straightforward about
their bias I think that for example I'm
very respectful towards MSNBC because
MSNBC is a liberal news network
it tells he was a liberal news network
Fox News got rid of fair and balanced
you can give him credit for that
daily wires a conservative publication
that does not pretend it's not a
conservative publication and I think
that as long as people are
straightforward with what they're saying
and don't try to you know throw in hasty
generalizations don't try to throw in
any any bias that's not admitted we can
we can do some good things here I think
if people report on the news I'm trying
I'm trying to think of the best way to
say it if people report on the events
and not their interpretation they leave
the interpretation up to you we would
have a much better more understanding
society so it's amazing to watch with
with folks like you and and I'm friend
of the cattle capture of another student
at the school is that it seems like
there there are a lot of people who are
honestly seeking more information people
who are going through in an intellectual
journey obviously you're going through
that an intellectual and emotional
journey and I have a ton of respect for
that because the minute you minute that
journey stops you stop being a human
being well I think that you Kyle for
example he's somebody that I have a deep
understanding for Kyle represents not in
his own way but what was done with him a
bit of hypocrisy if you ask me I think
that a lot of people went out and said
here's the left parading these kids
around and then the nra found a student
from Stoneman Douglas it was pro-gun and
said look at this kid who's pro-gun from
Stoneman Douglas well there's no
question I mean I was one of the people
pushing Kyle so I and and I will be
admit I will be open about the fact that
what I was doing was essentially saying
look
say that there is a monolithic opinion
at Stoneman Douglas is inaccurate here's
a student who feels a different way and
who actually in my opinion was going out
and trying to work with people on both
sides of the aisle at least
legislatively and try and meet with as
many people on both sides of the aisle
as possible that's why I'm appreciative
what you're doing but yeah I mean this
this does raise the larger question of
how do you think that we and the media
should be treating people who are 17
years old then again I was there so I
was syndicated calm when I was 7
columnist when I was 17 but my own
perspective when I was 17 was that I
better learn things fast because you're
not seventeen forever and nobody's gonna
pay attention to you just for your age
sure I have a question for you sure I
I've see I saw an article of yours I
that was here's a list of all the dumb
things I've said yeah of all what
someone you said at 17 that you are not
a fan let's see I wrote a piece when I
was 18 talking about enemy civilian
casualties would be saying essentially
that I had very little care about them
because I was more interested in
protecting the American soldiers the
piece was really badly phrase it's a bad
piece there was a piece that I wrote on
Israel and Palestinians when I was 19 I
believed I was bad I would say that most
of the stuff that I've said that was bad
the ratio of me saying stupid stuff to
not stupid stuff it was much higher when
I was younger and then gradually over
time you hope to get better at it
obviously but yeah I mean they're a
bunch of columns that that I wrote when
I was 18 19 20 years old that I just
think are not very good and I've openly
stated I don't think that they're very
good there's one from 2006 when I was 22
that about need the use of espionage a
lot of prosecute people or sedition a
lot of prosecute people that I think is
an idiotic column you know I was been
writing million words a year since I was
17 years old so there's a lot there
there's a lot there's a lot of stupid
crap I've written and that's why I have
a lot of sympathy for what you're going
through and it's hard to do it in public
I mean it's hard to do it in public I
know I get everything's gonna get picked
apart too I mean I'm sure I'll say
things right now that I'm incredibly
proud of that I'm when I'm 34 will say
I'm full of crap for no question
interested in seeing that day yeah well
I mean I think that that's the journey
that we all go through and it's it's
it's interesting and fun to watch people
who are actually trying to go through
that journey as opposed to sort of
battening down the hatches and being in
that box I'm gonna ask you some more
about that while your sources of
information are in just a second but
first let's talk about your hiring
process so hiring used to be hard
multiple job sites stacks of resumes a
confusing
review process but today hiren can be
easy you only have to go to one place to
get it done
zip recruiters comm /a been guest zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each and every
one and spotlights the top candidates so
you never miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate through the site
within the first day with results like
that it is no wonder that zip recruiter
is the highest rated hiring site in
America and right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
slash been guest that zip recruiter comm
/b + gu est zip recruiter comm slash
been guest we use it here at the daily
wire our offices if we have to replace
employees because they're annoying me
zip recruiter is the place to go zip
recruiter comm slash been guest for the
special deal it is the smartest way to
hire ok so Cameron let's talk about
where you get your information since you
know you say that you were a progressive
from a very young age I was a
conservative from as long as I can
remember so I again I sympathize from
the opposite point of view what sources
of information do you do you look at and
how do you how do you gather that
information and then sift through it
because sure I read everything from CNN
to Fox News Today the wire to Young
Turks I try to read everything because I
think that there are common themes in
everything that's presented I think that
I can get the story from everything
that's presented and I will pick out the
bias and everything that's presented and
assess my principles and see what I
think about it I really don't like
identifying with a party I think that
like George Washington said the parties
are a bunch of garbage
I vote for people know the people I
haven't voted but I will vote for a
matter of fact I turned 18 six days
after the election this year but the
point is I vote for people now the
people I vote for are normally Democrats
but I also see flaws on both ends so I'm
I'm really genuinely willing to vote for
somebody on either side of the aisle
okay so what are your central principles
just politically speaking politically
speaking I think that the the way I see
it is very often the Republican platform
is based off of modeling our decisions
off the past and the rights of the
individual whereas I think that
Democratic platform is basically
modeling our decisions on what we want
the future to be and the rights of the
people as a whole and I think there are
strengths in both and flaws in both I
think that Republican views of the
rights of the individual can lead to a
lack of understanding for certain groups
of people whereas I think that the
Democratic views of the rights of the
people will very often be difficult for
individuals it's it's it's a
double-edged sword it really is but both
sides have I said this before both sides
have some amazing public servants and
both sides have some really crappy ones
for sure I mean the way that that you
know I tend to think about politics is
that the role of government is not
necessarily the way I want society to
run meaning that as somebody who's a
religious Jew for example I believe a
lot of things about how people should
act I don't think the government should
get involved in nearly any of it because
I don't think it's my place to basically
tell people what to do as a whole what
that means that I do require a strong
social fabric and it seems to me like
one of the things you're trying to do is
build up a strong social fabrics I'm
gonna try and convert you to be a
conservative right here by basically
saying that government is a secondary
priority when it comes to creating
better communities then when it comes to
ensuring communities are safer and
smarter and better most of that can be
done through conversations between
individuals who don't feel like the
government is trying to force a
particular perspective or trying to get
into anybody's pocket or force anything
from above the minute one side uses
force things get really ugly I think one
of the reasons that we've seen such a
polarization or politics is because
people on both sides of the aisle expect
government to solve all of their
problems if there's a hurricane the
Washington Post says it's Trump's fault
and if the economy does great the right
says that's Trump's that's Trump's
benefit and in it feels to me like none
of this is real that the reality is most
of the relationships we have with other
folks our relationships we do have
one-on-one or in the context of a
community that we share together and
that doesn't require necessarily
legislative input or guys with guns
coming to your front door and trying to
force you to do things
sure well I'm gonna offer you my two
cents sure know by the end of this
you're gonna be a staunch liberal okay
let's make it happen just or rightists
you by the way I'm very very thirsty
right now my lips are very dry but I
can trigger again if you gave me one
that says Alex Jones tears and it's
pictures of Alex joy might be able to
agree on that you know it's an
intellectual property issue we'll talk
about that but so I was in Chicago for a
bit and Chicago I think is a strong
example of the ways that that liberal
idealism has failed in the ways that
liberal idealism needs to be there and
I'll explain so I was when I say I was
in Chicago I was not visiting the bean I
was an angle what I was in one of the
most violent neighborhoods in the
country and I was there with a lot of
young people who live in Chicago and who
have lost family members almost every
friend I have in Chicago has directly
lost at least one family member to to
gun violence and whereas somebody who
disagrees in my disagrees violence
utilizing it done yes yes and I saw I
saw some interesting things I saw the
negative results of gentrification which
I believe can sometimes be positive and
sometimes be very negative and I also
saw the need for opportunity now my
general view is the reason I identify as
liberal is in this country to be
successful you need to pull up your
bootstraps
but not everybody has access to the
boots and I think that things need to be
done in neighborhoods like Chicago where
there are a lot of cultural issues but
there are also a lot of issues that
can't really be solved by fixing the
culture there are people in
neighborhoods there that have been
pushed out of other neighborhoods the
South and West Side have very little
access to healthy food I know a friend
who has to walk almost six miles every
day to get food that is very often
either expired or very unhealthy and
that leads to a lot of obesity which
limits certain job opportunities I've
seen a lot of people who are on welfare
and abuse and a lot of people who are on
welfare and can't get a job I think that
there are certain things that can be
done to you to have the government aid
these people and I think there are
certain ways that government aid has
failed these people so it's it's really
something that I need to take an econ
class or a finance class or any of those
to really fully understand but through
my eyes the government as long as we are
such a strong country as long as we are
a country that should really be serving
as a beacon for the rest of the world
not just morally but really in in in
every sense I think that there are
things we can do to help people out so
this is this is one area where when I
was 17 years old I can say safely I've
gotten more libertarian since I was 17
years old I wrote a book when I
20 about the social liberalism inherent
in kind of the in in the movement of
American politics and I talked
specifically about the power of
government to help control what I
thought was the epidemic of pornography
that I thought was swamping young men
which it basically has and one of the
things that I suggested is that
government could be involved in helping
to stop this and over time I've become
less sanguine about the possibility of
government specifically because when you
see people who you disagree with run the
government what you realize and this is
something again they may realize as you
get older because I realized it as I got
older when you're 17 you look at the
adults and you think they must know what
they're doing and then once you and then
once you hit about 25 you look around
you realize they're the same people you
went to school with you realize
everybody's kind of dumb and young
people are dumb and old people are dumb
and everybody's kind of dumb and that
means that dumb people in charge of a
bunch of power do dumb things and no
matter how much they think they're
helping they generally are not so leave
me alone which is I could spin that on
you a bit and what I believe is a fair
way sure in libertarian views those dumb
people can also press the nude buttons
well I mean the you mean as far as the
there has to be a collective defense yes
right I mean there has to in the rarest
of circumstances you do have to have the
ability to collectively mobilize to
protect your life for example and so
having an army that's available to fight
off terrorists is is one thing and I
think that there's generally wide
agreement at least in the constitutional
structure on one you can go to war which
is why I'm very much in favor of the
idea that Congress should be declaring
war or not the president unilaterally
declaring war I don't think the
president should really be able to just
push a button and hit somebody in Syria
with a missile I think that Congress
should have to declare war for that to
happen the way the Constitution was
structured was to create all sorts of
gridlock so that only an overwhelming
majority of people could get anything
done and that was supposed to help sift
out a lot of the problems are really the
only Constitution that serves to protect
the people from the government as
opposed to the government from the
people exactly and to protect my
entrenched minorities against against
the tyranny of the majority as they
talked about in Federalist 51 and with
that said defense is one area where the
Congress was supposed to declare war
that was an area where where it required
you know a fair bit of pushing in order
to make that happen and you know there
are certain roles of government that
cannot be done anywhere else basically
defense is a public good but some of the
stuff that you're talking about I'm not
as a public good and not only that I'm
not sure the government is very good at
it basically government is good at
breaking things I think and and so if we
have to break something abroad then
government is quite good at that if we
have to break something at home all you
have to just put government in charge of
it sure I think that I think there are
benefits and and a lot of drawbacks to
both small and big government I think
the government is too big I think that a
lot of people who want smaller
government want the government to be too
small but I also think that in defence
of a big government I'm not a big
government guy necessarily but in
defence of the concept the more people
are involved with government the more
you can use the system against itself if
you need to explain that so basically
the government overstep is is a problem
because we've seen it fail other
countries but I think that discussing
other countries is occasionally used in
a double standard because if I'm talking
about gun control in another country
they'll say well we can't talk about
other countries but if I talk about you
know but then they'll say well look at
Mouse at all you know I think that we
need to create a more respectful
dialogue around basing our own ideas off
of other countries close to the
comparison works yes yes so I think that
having a big government allows more
people to get involved with the
government it allows more people to be
part of it and I think that the more
people that are part of the government
the more representation there is the
fairer a lot of people are treated I
mean it's how it's how I feel about a
lot of police officers in neighborhoods
in areas like Chicago in areas like
Milwaukee that deal with a lot of gun
violence and there's also some turmoil
between the people in the area and the
police I believe that most neighborhoods
should be policed by people who live
there and I like to kind of apply that
to the government the idea of having a
neighborhood police by people who live
there are they understand the community
they understand how the community works
you can create a dialogue in a respect
between the people and the police my
father's a reserve police officer I'm I
have some yeah
I respect the idea of the police a lot
but far too many respect too much and
far too many people don't respect enough
but I treat that the way I treat the
government I think the more people who
are involved the more representation we
can have and the more ideas can have a
voice okay so let's talk a little bit
about your perspective on Second
Amendment issues in terms of you know
you talk about kind of making better
arguments let's let's steel man it so
you you get to play me for a second so
you get to be the guy who makes the case
for the second man what do you think is
the strongest case for the
an amendment for the Second Amendment I
think that if the government becomes
evil you got overthrow I think that's
the general okay I also think that the
individual has the right to protect
themselves not that my where we differ
on the Second Amendment is how far that
right should extend like for example
have a question for you how do you feel
about the National Firearms Act of 1930
something I don't have a problem with
that long machine guns in 1934 yeah did
they're okay I don't think people in the
country should be able to carry RPGs
around and the question is does do
semi-automatic rifles like the ar-15
should they fall into the category of
things like RPGs or should they fall
into the categories of things like
handguns right what are the that's the
real question is whether they should
fall into the category of things like
muskets which is which is what the
second member was originally meant to be
exactly back when the Second Amendment
was written you which is a rifle you
could shoot a bullet and I could I could
take you down before he can reload and
that's fine because you know a lot of
people say that the reason the sacrament
was written is because they want the
citizens to be armed the way the
military is that's a problem for me
because I can get drone to pretty hard
right well at least at least to the
extent that you have the capacity to
defend yourself against government
tyranny and you can't do it with
handguns alone yes you said it about
fascism you said that the government
will come to your door and at the end of
the day their point had gotten even tiny
to do something well that's right and so
if there's too many examples of the
government doing that with regard to
basic rights that we would all consider
basic rights in various countries around
the world that the possibility one of
the things that deters the possibility
of the government overstepping its
bounds the knowledge that if they do
then things go wrong at the very least
it'll be a bloody battle I mean this is
why Texans aren't particularly afraid of
mass gun confiscation because the
government would never attempt a mask on
confiscation in Texas things would go
wildly wrong even they tried gun
confiscation or gun turns it turns in
Australia they only got one-third of the
weapons so weapons are still available
in Australia one of the big problems
that I have I guess with it with the
with the arguments in favor of gun
control is that very often they're
predicated on a version of what I wish
the government could do as opposed to
what the government has actually proven
itself capable of doing and balancing
that with whatever right is at stake and
this I think holds true for my general
perspective on politics which is the
government what does the government
proved itself competent at well sir and
I think that one of the things I can use
to defend my stance on it is Trump's
running the government right now and I
think that certain guns should be
regulated by the government
I don't think Trump can regulate his own
mouth so the question is should the
government be regulating weapons when
people like that can be elected the way
to fix these issues is to put people in
office who we know are going to be
morally just now that is very subjective
term and that could very often be
interpreted different ways but I think
the way we we agree we figure out just
how far the government can go here is
say look what else is regulated I mean I
need to take a driver's test to drive a
car no I don't like the car argument
because cars exist to take you from
point A to point B as opposed to put a
bullet in somebody but it is the
government regulating something that is
in some way an infringement upon certain
people's rights but constitutionally as
far as I'm concerned and I've only read
the Constitution I think once and I've
them I only read John J's Federalist
Papers and he didn't contribute anything
to that it was 585 amia technically I
believe that I had the constitutional
right to drive whatever goddamn car I
please at whatever age as long as I'm
not killing anybody well let's take guns
into example I think that it's in
credits far too easy to buy a gun I
think that if the shooter at my school
spent five minutes with a specialist
they would have said you need a doctor
not a gun now that's basically did right
I mean that's the that's one of the
problems for everybody more than 48
times exactly and the shooter in
Jacksonville that would tragic shooting
that occurred very recently they got
almost no media attention the the
shooter in Jacksonville I believe the
police were called in him 26 times but
certainly more than 20 yeah which is why
a policy that I've recently started to
consider I don't really know the legal
terminology I should use is creating
something where if you get the police
called on you 15 times you put under
review to buy a weapon now that's
unconstitutional but the police are
called them you 15 times I think
something's going on with you well it's
not necessarily unconstitutional in the
sense that David French has proposed
this in National Review so that and I
support this proposal the idea of a
friend or family member being able to
preemptively go to a court and petition
to have your Second Amendment right
taken away on the basis that you're a
danger to yourself or others that is
that's not unconstitutional and would
probably be upheld under under judicial
review I think that's that's a way to a
way to talk about it I don't talk more
about this because this is fun and it's
interesting to get your perspective as a
young person and we'll talk about like
where you hope politics is going to be
in
years and also what you think you could
tell other 17 year olds about getting
involved in politics should they do it
should they not we'll get to all that in
a second but first let's talk about your
sleep quality there is nobody on the
planet like you so why would you buy a
generic mattress built for somebody else
helix sleep built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete they use
the answers to match your body type and
sleep preference to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper whether you can plush or firm
bed with helix there is no more guessing
there's no more confusion just go to
helix sleep calm slash been guests take
their two-minute sleep cause they will
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life for
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty you get it stride out for
a hundred nights risk-free so what do
you have to lose right now helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders again up to 125 dollars
off at helix sleep comm /a Ben guessed
that helix sleep calm slash Ben guests
for 125 bucks off your mattress order my
wife and I got a helix sleep mattress it
is just fantastic it came in the mail
after we took the quiz we unwrapped it
it inflated right in front of us we toss
it on the bed frame we were good to go
it is so good we got one for my sister
for her wedding as well that's how good
these things are helix sleep calm slash
been guests for 125 bucks off your
mattress order okay so let's talk a
little bit about the politicians that
you do like you're looking up at 2020
you're actually gonna get to vote in
2020 which is very exciting so so which
politicians I assume you're not invoke
for president Trump so which politician
on the left side of the aisle is most
appealing to you as a 17 year old guy
soon to be 18 year old die sure I love
better O'Rourke I understand that a lot
of people are critical of and not
because of his DUI and his history as a
punk-rock person but I look at what he
proposes in Texas I look at his ability
to communicate with people and at the
end of the day I think that this guy
wants to serve his country and I'm
seeing less and less of those every day
so I'm not a hundred percent with him on
policy I am I can't say exactly what yet
because I'm still really working on
figuring out his platform and what I
believe it truly is but I believe that
Beto wants the best for this country and
I believe that at the end of the day
when push comes to shove bento will make
the decision he believes is most
effective for everyone in this country
as opposed to just those who will praise
him I I'm a big fan of people who are
willing to piss off the people who like
them if they think it's right I mean I
I know a lot of people and I'm dear
friends with who after coming on the
show will be upset with me for coming on
the show but I believe that conversation
is more important than in the short term
making people happy
I think the bento is not about making
people happy in the short term and
that's an example I don't think he's
gonna run I think even if he does be Ted
Cruz he might not run I'm not sure he'll
be Ted Cruz he's a Democrat running for
healthcare in Texas but you could
certainly say this this campaign of his
is is incredibly impressive well one of
the things that that's kind of fun about
doing this particular episode of the
show is that normally I'm the young guy
on set and now I get to play the the old
guy on set which is really fun I and I'm
getting the thrill that I that I only
get normally when I speak to my own
children because you're literally young
enough to be my son which is insane I'd
have to be really productive at like 17
years old but it's that's crazy man but
one of the things that you know has
occurred to me is that over time I've
spent enough time spend a lot of time
with politicians now because you've been
talking with a lot of them I've spent a
lot of time with politicians and I feel
like I spend my life bursting people's
bubbles about how politics works in what
politics our politicians are idiots man
I mean like I'm just telling you now
like as much as I'm sure better luck is
a nice guy maybe you'll meet him and
you'll be super impressed maybe already
have met him and you're super impressed
I can name on maybe two fingers people
who have not disappointed me in politics
over the last 20 years ago and people
who have not disappointed me as in
politics
oh boy now I'm trying to get to two
fingers um senator Lee from Utah is
genuine Mike Lee okay from Utah is a
genuine guy and Nikki hailey the
ambassador to the UN sure those those
would be the two that come to mind
everyone else pretty much everyone else
has disappointed me in one way or
another simply because politics is a
dirty rough game and most of politics
ends up in the end being about avoiding
the solving of issues in order to pander
for votes it's in many ways my biggest
problem with senator Rubio now the
townhall you're familiar with my
conversation with Rubio I incredibly can
appropriately likened him to a school
shooter I'm embarrassed by that I
incredibly apologetic for it I don't
think it was right I don't agree with
pretty much anything Rubio says in a
policy standpoint but if I make a
mistake I own up to it and that wasn't
appropriate that being said I think that
he was
not too easy I think he was able to
politician sidestep out of a lot of
questions a lot of people are but he was
doing it and I was pissed and I said
this guy's not getting out of here
without being exposed for the career
politician he is because senator Rubio
is a career politician you've seen it he
ran for president yeah I believe that I
know where this guy is where this guy's
goals are not being said I treated him
unfairly I did you know but I don't I
think that his policies have been
negative for the state of Florida I
believe that he was president he would
be incredibly negative for the country
but this guy is not someone who murdered
17 people and that's that's that's it
that was a big whiff on my part and I
get why I did it
so where were your chief political
priorities because the fact is that you
know senator Rubio is is a you know tea
party Republican try my priorities are
people who are more interested in doing
what they think is best for the country
and putting party aside I think that
part that someone who is clearly playing
for their party as I've seen senator
Rubio do as I've seen pretty much
everybody else do needs to get out I
think that my generation we were gonna
discuss the future here I'll tell you I
think my generation is going to do that
I think if my generation learns how to
discuss things with each other we're
gonna learn that we've been failed we
have in many ways we've been failed by
politics before because politics became
exactly what Washington said it would
Washington said and I'm not a Washington
fan I think that anybody who owned
slaves is I'm not going to call a be a
fan of I like the things they did that
were good I will not like them as people
because I think that slavery is immoral
and I'm a big fan of Hamilton for his
criticism of it but Washington said
political parties I don't want to try
and quote him directly but but they were
the means by which people who were
manipulative and evil would come into
power I think that there will be always
be parties I don't like groupthink but
as long as there's groupthink let's try
to make it positive groupthink but Rubio
and and many others are examples of
folks who are doing what they do so they
can keep their friends happiest they can
maintain power if I believe that what
I'm doing that pisses off my friends
will make the world a better place I'll
piss off my friends I politicians should
be public servants they should not be
politicians I mean I guess the question
that I have we know we can go for a
while on on Washington and why I think
that it's okay to call people heroes who
were abiding by a moral standard that at
the time was considered
widely considered not as bad as it is
now even though it was evil at the time
obviously and is evil now and we we
uphold people who do good things and we
and we can criticize I've actually
believed that the definition of people
as heroes and villains in history is
very difficult one I think typically you
have to judge people for who they are
and that's usually they do some good
things and usually they do some bad
things but the stuff we like Washington
for he was a hero about and one of those
things was the role of government when
we talk about the senator Rubio you know
I don't want to get harsh with you but
but you're casting aspersion what what
about senator Rubio makes you cast
aspersions at him as opposed to say you
know better or Roark who obviously is is
running inside a political party he
doesn't seem like somebody who's focused
dramatically on reaching across the
aisle he's down the line person on the
left where do you think that senator
Rubio to take just that example since
you took him sure is is more of a career
politician than anybody else he's in the
senator in the Congress sure I believe
the best I can do is assess their
behaviors in the past and I believe that
you'll see from his record and I'm not
fully done really vetting it not that
I'm vetting it implies that I have some
authority I'm not really done looking
through it but better o'rourke is
somebody who applied what he was doing
to the current situation I think that
his views I think that when people call
politicians shills and end and evil for
changing their perspectives over time I
think that's incredibly unfair because
I'm less impressed with somebody who was
so statically believed the same thing
for 30 years
you know people criticize a lot of
people for that people refer their votes
in the past I think if they explain why
it's fair to to give him credit for that
but I I look at senator Rubio I look at
his history and I see this guy ran for
president
this guy has consistently been bringing
himself up and up and and I don't see a
connection to the people that that Pete
folks like Peto him better is just an
example it's one of the things I respect
about Bobby Kennedy Bobby Kennedy is
either is loved by many hated by many I
think he's a little bit more loved than
the know he is yeah but you know Bobby
Kennedy was a big conservative for a
while a lot of people forget that he was
or he was ordering the FBI to wiretap
Martin Luther King jr. he was a big
war hound before he instantly you know
not instantly but quickly changed
against the war and it makes you think
is this guy an opportunist which was
some might call him or is he somebody
who changed his perspective and and
that's that's what I look at I look at
somebody who I think is willing to do
what they think is best for the people
I don't think better O'Rourke is first
of all I think that door work is a lot
more classic of a liberal and I'm more
of a classical liberal than what a lot
of people are look I don't like saying
the left or the right too much but a lot
of people on the left are becoming and I
believe that Beto is a moderate guy he
was willing to work with people as
opposed to just try and completely
rewrite the book I don't want to rewrite
the book I want to erase the stuff
that's bad and I think that Rubio is is
out there just doing what he thinks will
make the Republicans happiest okay so I
have one more question for you and the
question is going to be about what you
think you can learn from the older
generation because you criticize people
who are older a lot in the past and here
as well what do you think we got to keep
from the older generation what do you
think we ought oh we got a ditch but if
you want to hear Cameron cask easy
answer you actually have to be a daily
water subscriber to subscribe over at
daily wire go to daily wire comm click
subscribe and you can hear the end of
our conversation there okay well Cameron
thank you so much for stopping by I
think you're one of the good guys and
even though we disagree on politics I
hope that we keep the conversation going
is one of things I really appreciate
about you at least trying to do that
thanks much for stopping by I really
appreciate everything but right now
let's talk about
[Laughter]
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy Boren associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stephens edited by Alex Singaram audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jess wah all vera and title
graphics by Cynthia and Gullu the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright board publishing 2018
[Music]